I'm a semi safe I'm from Egypt I work in
about Egypt and this first time for me
to attend the World Economic Forum
yesterday I went for the social
intervene early for this year 2011 and I
would transfer the good opportunity to
attend this meeting and I see is a very
important thing for us you'll find this
a link between civil society and the big
company because this is is a very very
important opportunity to opening the new
job holy news I I think and in
circumference for us two days we
discussed a lot of what is the
relationship between the civil society
and company and immature oh and the
foundation and I think in Egypt we like
to open many activity with with image oh
and I think this is very important to
invite me use to help
help and this activity and they take
mean experience to work with us and we
needed to do a big awareness about the
same color chart for volunteer and this
is very important experience or zoos
many of attending and this two days are
both discussed about this a show about
people and arrow and how you can take
many experienced forces thank you and I
hope and a future we can open many
activity and the meaning work of all
zeros